texas governor greg abbott talked with
local officials around the state about
an hour ago he has issued a state
disaster declaration for 54 texas
counties the governor has also requested
and received federal disaster
declarations for 18 counties and he
plans to send another 1 000 national
guard troops to houston today governor
abbott is with us from houston governor
good morning thank you so much for
joining us
good morning thank you
does houston have what it needs
well listen uh this is an enormous
challenge and we are making sure that we
continue to provide houston all that it
needs as well as fema is assisting
tremendously i want you to know that
today
we are delivering another 150 boats as
well as 300
high water vehicles to assist in the
rescue program understanding that our
first and foremost priority right now
is to ensure that we continue to save
every life we can secondarily of course
you were talking about the evacuees we
are providing more resources for
evacuees as well as
the the city of dallas is opening up an
evacuee center that will be able to
house 5 000 evacuees san antonio will be
hosting more evacuees we will actually
have airlift operations out of galveston
today to begin to remove some of the
evacuees to other locations to make sure
that they will all be accommodated in
ways they need for this temporary basis
governor i have to ask you i spent some
time with some of the rescuees last
night who arrived
on dump trucks they didn't have shoes on
they were soaking wet some with pets
with babies with them um
and and they were really scared uh the
mayor of houston as you know is
defending his decision not to call for a
mandatory evacuation of the six and a
half million residents do you still
think that was a wise idea
listen the the
the time uh for making that
determination has passed is
no need for us to relitigate that issue
right now what we have to focus on again
is making sure that we continue this
this evacuation process get people out
of harm's way get them relocated and
then begin the rebuilding process
i want to bring in gail king my
colleague who is in new york gail all
right thanks norah governor the
president has said he will be traveling
to texas as soon as the trip can be made
without causing disruption in the wake
of this hurricane right now he's
scheduled to come tomorrow is that the
best time for him to come
the place he will be going to will not
be houston so it will not be getting
into harm's way or interrupting the
evacuations or the emergency response in
the houston area he most likely will be
going closer to where the hurricane hit
land
and that's where i will be going today
to meet with the fema administrator
brock long
we will be surveying the corpus christi
area as well as areas like rockport that
were hardest hit by the hurricane
these are areas where we have already
begun the cleanup process but it just
goes to show the magnitude of the storm
uh where the focus for the past few days
has been the torrential rain in houston
uh people have already forgotten
the the horrific way that the corpus
christi area got hit by this hurricane
just a few days ago governor i imagine
you've spoken to the president a number
of times you're satisfied with his
engagement and his response thus far
the engagement and response by the
president the white house by his cabinet
and by fema have been actually
remarkable we begin working with them
a week or two in advance of this and
i've been in constant contact with
either the white house
or fema on a daily basis and they
provided texas everything that we need
whenever texas asked for anything the
answer was yes and so we've been very
pleased with their collaborative
response but also as brock long the fema
administrator has made abundantly clear
publicly as well as to me
this is just the beginning of what will
be a very long process people can
remember
the the long time it took for people to
recover from katrina listen this area in
houston texas that was subject to this
flooding is going to take a very long
time for us to be able to overcome
governor the houston police chief
alcevado said listen this scene breaks
your heart but it's texas and we will
get through it
exactly and one thing he was talking
about uh that you all were talking about
earlier and that is uh not only the way
that first responders were able to help
out but you've seen countless stories
about the way our fellow texans have
come together bringing out their own
votes helping to rescue their fellow
texans this is typical texans helping
each other uh we rallied behind each
other at times like this and i could not
be more proud about my fellow texans
about the way they have helped their
neighbors respond to this challenge
governor the images are so
gut-wrenching what do you tell ordinary
americans and really people around the
world who want to help what should they
do and what should they not do in terms
of donations and giving and so forth
well for the the best way to make sure
that we can coordinate donations to a
single source and get it to the
emergency needs uh that are most dire
right now would be through the red cross
uh and people can go online to
redcross.org or or call 1-800 red cross
and that perhaps is one of the best ways
that people can help out i know there's
so many people who want to help out and
there's so many needs that we need to
have addressed these people going to the
shelters as you pointed out
they need cots they need blankets they
need towels things like that uh i want
you to know also that we are benefiting
from uh grocery stores like h-e-b and
walmart that are providing critical food
that are needed by these evacuees all
right governor thank you very much for
joining us this morning